we got some new merch made but it's only
exclusive for our petrie honors
so if you go on our patreon we got some
new tiers we got the coffee mug tear
and the hoodie tier and if you're
defibrillator you get
both so make sure you go to patreon
check that out and thank you guys so
much for supporting and enjoy the video
[Music]
have any of you guys ever been in a
situation where someone's trying to
surprise you with something and
you just don't really have that reaction
or vice versa
yeah nikki nikki uh was trying to do the
naked challenge with me
and she just freaked me the [ __ ] out
actually what's the naked challenge so
to tick-tock they do this thing where
a chick just comes up to you and drops
her clothes and she's completely naked
in front of you
and then you're supposed to film your
dude's reaction to that and usually the
guy's like
oh baby or whatever and i she just came
in my office
in the early morning it was like 10 a.m
and it was it's always dark in my office
i like it to be dark right yeah
and i was listening to a podcast or some
[ __ ] and she walks in
like behind me and i turn i'm like holy
[ __ ] [ __ ]
which is not the response that you want
to have this is your name
i don't remember no she didn't she was
devastated after
she was so sad and i was so embarrassed
did she have her makeup on
she was like dolled up and everything
was perfect but you were you were scared
though cause you didn't expect it at
that time it was just
what ended up happening too after i
think i remember correctly was
your reaction was just like you scared
me and then she was like i was just
trying to play
okay so i don't have the best eyesight
right so
my first initial reaction was not that
she was naked it was just that there was
a person here like a ghost like holy
[ __ ] just any presence was like oh [ __ ]
and it was a jump scare it's a classic
jump scare which i hate [ __ ] horror
movies because of jump scares
and so i it just it was a bad
combination i like the thought of
hearing like
seeing mickey getting ready all happy
and [ __ ] like listening to girls want to
have fun
and [ __ ] she even put in the earrings
and like everything are you guys naked
people
no yeah i'm not wow no what's naked
people yeah what are you just people
that don't have a problem being
naked i uh even if i have a a girlfriend
or something i always kind of turn
around to
change yeah i i do i don't mind
if i'm comfortable around that person
but i feel
bad for strangers because then
they might i don't want them to feel
embarrassed and i don't want them to
feel offended
so but if they were okay with it i would
take off my clothes
you were half naked when i got here true
when me and her in bed
and i'm naked if i need to sit up and
talk to her i always tuck the blanket
like this
[Applause]
you have a [ __ ] apron no i'm just
kidding
the only time i'm comfortable being
naked though is like if i'm in the
shower walking to the shower walking
back and forth from this room in the
shower whatever i'm naked
or if like we're having sex and we're
just full blown like when you go to the
bath the korean spa where everyone's
naked yeah you look naked there
i mean you look comfortable i think she
is naked
like you look comfortable naked there do
you remember the first time we went
i was like yeah i've heard horror
stories
they really grind you they exfoliate
yeah
you get i get too scared they [ __ ] go
in yeah
yeah i get too scared no yeah i guess
outside of those three things
what are those it's me uh showering
that's us yeah like you know or like if
i'm getting ready to go to the shower
casey's around the room
door's closed isaac's in his room uh and
he knows i'm about to shower so he
doesn't come in
and i'll walk around the bedroom naked
that's fine or sex
time fine or spa time fine
any other things out of that like if
we're done having sex i immediately just
really we're not immediately like in the
movies
yeah yeah let's do like pillow talk or
whatever and then once we're done i'm
like okay
we're good we're good we're good oh we
just pillow talk
yeah that's how you get married yep you
have to do that
you don't just go to sleep afterwards no
i try my hardest
but i can't so it's just nothing they
say i get into
it's very hard for me you need a ritual
but because me and nicky were like
love island love island like tv is great
yeah
you watch tv no we we watch tv and then
we talk about or no we we
bang and then we talk about how we're
gonna watch tv
[Laughter]
and then do you watch it we do oh that's
a good idea
yeah yeah i dated a girl who didn't like
tv watch
trash hated it what what how do you hate
tv
is it like the screeches like monitors
it's been just can't
the triangle that's crazy her parents
were killed by a tv
yeah oh no it fell on them what about fm
radio she's okay with fm radio
you know i don't think i've tuned into a
good fm station in a while
but um yeah i mean it's tough it's so we
didn't get along on a lot of things you
know tv's
very important when it comes to
conversation true are you a tv in the
bedroom kind of person
i have a huge tv that's so cool yeah we
have one too
on an arm and i like it pulls up way too
close to the bed
i'm like this yeah but it was for my old
house i didn't want to like get a new
smaller one so i just brought the old tv
yeah uh and uh it is and i have my nice
speakers because it oh
you know because in the living room it
doesn't work it's like money problems
really but
you guys get it uh but yeah i have this
whole thing in there and it's um i think
it emits so much light that i feel the
warmth oh
do you leave it on when you sleep no
okay good you should because it's like
getting the warmth of a woman
oh you can get a woman's screensaver
and there's a woman glad you're there
youtube videos that are like you know
you leave on for your dogs when they're
at home
10 hours of like a woman shuffling her
clothes around or like pots and pans
or yelling at you from the kitchen hey
[ __ ] off no no just like
i got no i know i know i know it's her
you know discovering
her passions in the kitchen
in the kitchen our [ __ ] clothing
right um
yeah no surprise why not yeah
anyway go ahead and slide into the dms
of here he's available girls
so anyway i have this really cute tick
tock here
from so this dad he posted his son's
reaction to his new bedroom
okay oh cool so here we go oh no
so it's uh the reaction that he was
expecting yeah so he titled it when you
surprised your son with his new paint
job in his room
ellipses his reaction was not what we
expected a giant confederate flag is
okay
i hate it it's john deere oh like the
tractor
yeah that's so cute because he's super
into farming he was that he was out
farming while
when they redid the rounds that's cool
yeah it's super cute okay here we go
that would have been me
that was rude
you painted without me
do you guys hear his voice crack yeah
was he sad yeah we should slap the [ __ ]
out of that kid for being ungrateful so
he's not he's not upset
he's not upset at the design he's upset
that they didn't do it together he's a
a little farmer what do you expect he
wants to do the labor he wanted to do
the labor
so he was really let down that that his
parents did it without him healthy yeah
he wanted he's like i'm not no
freeloader i'll have you know
i work for my food thank you it's so
[ __ ] cute because you hear it it's
like you said it without
me or you painted without me but yeah so
then um
yeah so people even commented that it's
like oh the way his voice broke when he
said that part and then
the dad was like yup that was tough so
apparently he was pretty upset but then
once
after the initial meltdown was
simmered he actually liked it he um it
turns out that he was more upset
at the thought that his sister helped
but then once
once they clarified like no your sister
didn't help he was like oh okay
as long as she didn't get to have any
fun then that's that's that's so better
he had fomo
on the painting yes and he's like i
can't believe she got to paint
my room yeah i was a big brother and
uh i would never let my brother in my
room and i know that you
i would have so just terrible i was a
terrible big brother but if i
if i thought that he was in my room i
would be like oh he's going through my
stuff he's stealing my
you know as a little brother that's true
one time
because one time i came home from school
and all my
good baseball cards the ones that were
worth money were all crumpled up
oh no he's dead what was the year
one time six years oh yeah too old
between me and my bro i did the same
[ __ ] i would go into his uh
guitar case in the closet when he left
just jam the [ __ ] out and [ __ ] up those
strings as hard as possible and then
go back i would just play his music and
try to rewind it back to like the
perfect place so then like that's what
we
think you're doing we are doing it yeah
yeah and why i couldn't be in his room
but i
[ __ ] yelled at you i got my i got
beat by him he would hog tie me with my
own underwear
and leave me on the floor yeah dude
i deserve it yeah i'm a big brother but
i didn't have my own space
i always had to share a room with my two
brothers because my sister
is a girl and so my parents wouldn't
cohabitate us and so i
never had my own freedom it's just like
it's like i'm fostering cats right now
and i have the mom cat and she just sits
there while all the cats like fly around
her
all the little kittens are flying around
the room and that's how i felt you have
two other brothers
yeah two little two little brothers and
they're just jumping around you and
you're just like papa lying like
well that was zero privacy like zero
respect for your for your belongings i
had no belongings everything was shared
everything was communism
we had two sega genesis because i
wouldn't share
you brad i was a brat and i had my own
phone line why do you have two sega
genesis because i wouldn't let him play
my sega genesis
and they let that go by my parents would
never i was a
i was the first i was spoiled wow oh
have you ever been
did you only have one younger brother
only one they couldn't handle anymore
we had our anc my brother was an anchor
baby born in florida
you know he's the american citizen so he
could be president but you can't my
brother can be president
i hope he becomes a president i hope
well i do too he could win he's one of
the nicest people i've ever known
we're such we're best friends now but
when we were younger up until
jesus up until like i was 25 i barely
knew the guy
oh yeah but you know things always come
around
why do you think that that was i moved
out at a young age he kept
living with my folks my folks moved to
like three
other places and the furthest of which
was hawaii so i never went to go visit
maybe once a year
but he got into like all kinds of
trouble
he went to live with all these different
we live with my cousin with my parents
and eventually um when i was old enough
i invited him to come live with me and
then we got to know each other
i also started smoking weed again at 25.
it was a good connector you guys blazed
out and chilled i don't do it anymore
but i will say our relationship
was the foundation of it was when we
were getting high together we would just
talk helps yeah totally helped and
because we didn't really have anything
in common except our parents were crazy
what would you
ask him to live with you then uh he was
struggling and i needed rent money oh
you know he needed a place other than
where he was and
i was i was renting a place in santa
monica and the rent was super high and i
was like i could use an extra
700 bucks or 600 bucks or whatever it
was and so
that's that's our journey oh yeah and
now i'm
a great big brother i'm positive
i think so but i was such a dick for so
long but i can i'm glad i can say i'm a
good big brother now oh that's awesome
we'll ask him
we don't believe you i know he's all he
still doesn't [ __ ] even share the
plates
he has his own freaking plates his own
silverware yeah
i think no matter what as a big brother
because sometimes you
lay down the law in certain situations
your your little brother's always got
some [ __ ] with you
oh yeah cause like my little brother i
swear to god i was so cool to this kid
but sometimes if you get him going he's
like oh man steve had it so
set there was one week where he didn't
even do laundry and i'm like
one week i didn't do laundry that's all
you got i
would love to have you as a big brother
yeah you're acting like i tied you up
with your underwear and [ __ ] yo my
brother would make me go outside
and be a target while he shoots me with
rubber bands
that's cool like i was just a [ __ ]
little [ __ ] like
i look back and you were happy to do it
you were no i hated it
you were just happy to have your
brother's attention
yeah i guess so
[Music]
you